one of my first things ever to do after
idle and I don't know if it is one of
your first things you probably dancing
she's your kid but we met and you were
back up dancing and I was doing this
independent yes you had we're just one
just one idle idle we were at a we're in
a Walmart parking lot this is not a joke
I signed to like 2 a.m. and like we were
just out there and she was dancing and I
was like god you're beautiful and I
danced like that maybe one day no and
then turns out I just sing well
sometimes and anyway but it was the most
random thing because I was so excited
because I had no friends you don't even
know this part I'm about to tell you but
I had no friends because at home I did
but I was working in LA I didn't know
anyone and so it was just nice to like
see a Texas girl just so nice and you're
kind and I really needed somebody to be
kind in that moment and you were and so
thank you in LA I all my friends were in
Texas and so I was like well I so
remember this and for like the entire
time this was a little longer than week
it was along time ago with five years
ago you know we were like 20 which is
yeah I told everyone that would listen
to me I was like Kelly is the nicest
most amazing person she's gonna be huge
and you know listen oh I'm psychic you
know look at this yeah what else do you
project yeah right that was funny
because you remember we were dancing on
a stage that they built in the movie in
the parking lot and we ran back to the
break room yes yes for smoke breaks and
Wesley stripping to keep it cool and be
like so professional yes yeah we're like
hey and then we're running through the
aisles to get back on the stage I was so
happy to have gotten the job I mean it
was just like it was a fun experience
but that picture I found I couldn't
believe I found like our style
everything everything three jeans I was
quite very comfortable actually yeah I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not going to stop yep still here not
going anywhere I see you don't walk away
from this